This is it ladies and gentlemen: The Final Episode
Castle Rock season 1 and boy is it gonna
cost some controversy. But before we get into that
I just wanted to say
a huge Thank You to those who've watched and subcribed
My channel has exploded because of you guys and I
hope that you stayed tuned even
if I do another show because you know i'm gonna be back here
for season 2. The finale begins
with the warden Lacy and the kid back in the water tank.
Lacy prepares a nutritions lunch of an apple,
the fruit used to attempt Adam in the Garden of Eden,
bread, the body of Christ, and a moon pie
He uses the walking stick to move the
tray, as to not get touched before getting of his gloves
and smoking a Malboro,,
the same brand warden Porter examinated in episode 1.
Judging by his parking spot being painted
over the bucket of cigarettes and Lacy's overall appearance
this scene likely happened shortly before the events
of episode 1. The events which set this story emotion.
Lacy brings out a gun and pointed out the kid
clearly torned he should pull the trigger or not
the kid even leans in closer almost
as if tatting him, but Lacy doesn't go through with it
as his told us in voiceovers the previous episodes
there's still doubt whether what his doing
is right. And this idea
of doubt, not knowing for certain
who or what something is
plays a key role in understanding the ending
but we'll get to that in a bit. At Shawshank
warden Porter watches as it meets a
transfer to new prisons. Shawshank is
shutting down after its handling of recent scandals
specifically Zalescki, God rest his soul.
Notice the axe placement here
a nice note to Jackie who's seen in the next scene having
put one to the back of Gord's head, who
also happens to be a blood relative to Jack Torrance.
"Here's Johnny!" After the events of episode 9
the story picks up of where we left off in 8
Wendell is back in Castle Rock and Henry rushes off
in search of Ruth after getting a call from
Appleton, but we find out where Ruth is
staying at the top of Pangborn bridge, just like she did in
episode 5. The kid tells Molly that he needs
her help to convince Henry to
go out to the woods with him. The two of them need to be together
to get through the rift
and set everything right before the sound of the skisma disappear
trapping him there for good.
Now if you believe the kid is evil you can look
at this in different way, that the kid is merely using Henry
and his ability to
hear the skisma in order to travel to a different
world to spread his evil. The kid tells Molly
for Henry to meet him at Harmony Hill Cemetery
which those of you who ever read Salem's Lot
is where Mike Rianson digs up on dead Danny Clig.
Finally, Molly asked what she was like on
the other side to which the kid responds: "Happier".
Happier if you believe him but also dead
Molly
lives a voicemail to Henry telling him she needs to talk to him when his
car has been bombard by birds like the one who slanted
into the bus and he crushes into a pile of bricks and woods
talked about a rough day. After the tilted credits Molly
finds Ruth on the bridge and tries to cost her down
Ruth tells Molly she saw this moment many times
but when Molly tells her about how she had left
with Alan in the alternate time line she said
"First time you've said that"
Suggesting that something is different about what's happening now
warden Porter comes home and finds one of the kid's soap
carvings in her image. Back in 1991
young Henry and Matthew adventured into the woods
Henry is caught in a lie by his father
about hearing the skisma. Matthew tells
his son that Ruth has been cheating and
once she's gone the two of them can live pure
in the cathedral of God's voice. When Henry
asks what his gonna do he recites a line from
"Romans" 6:23
"For the wages of sin, death."
implying that Matthew is going to kill Ruth
for her adultering saying
"She's left me no choice."
Henry runs from his father as we transition back to
present day. Dead birds covered in snow
and Henry is woken by a passer by who blames it on
global warming
Wendell walks into the forest and comes across the crime scene
of the RV. Willie is there
likely indicating that he was the one who killed Odin
or he probably would've rushed off unless he's trying to set up
Henry. He sees Wendell but doesn't
say him anything just give him a creepy stare
Henry arrives back to Ruth to find that she's okay.
She seem to can't find her queen chess piece.
The last time
we saw it was on the table near the front door at the end of
episode 7. Molly tells Henry about her time with the kid
but does a terrible job
at convincing him to meet him at the cemetery
First, by saying all the bad things that happened around him
coupled with the fact that Matthew and her died there
well for Molly in the alternate time line. Henry is being
rational here saying that the best course
of action would be to turn in the kid.
Henry goes to the police station were he finds
his son, who tells him
he also heard the skisma which is why he came back
Henry is detained with an eye witness, Willie, he tells them
that Henry had an argument with Odin a few days ago,
Odin who is now dead. Warden Porter goes to Molly
with the soap carving
asking where the kid is and telling her that Lacy was right
the kid is the Devil. Molly recognize it
as similar with the one that kid carved and left on her diagrama
Porter than shifts mumbling something to herself
almost as something is taking over her
kindly like something took over
Zaleski. She turns to the street and strike killed by
one of the Shawshank buses. Back at the station
Henry is question by the police. His DNA was found
in the RV and it's not looking good for him getting out of jail
any time soon.
Henry uses his one phone call to call Molly who's being
questioned by the death of warden Porter
next to a bus of restless inmates.
He tells Molly
that he's rescind to the fact that he's gotta be put away for a long time
and asks her to take Wendell to his mother in Boston and
to keep driving to start a new life.
Molly then tells Henry where the kid is
Harmony Hill Cemetery where we see him waiting
Henry is brought to jail while the cops descend on the kid
arresting him in front of his grave: The Deaver Boy.
Remember, according to the kid in the alternate time line
he's the son of Ruth and Matthew who didn't passed away in childbirth.
Molly tries to consult Wendell telling him his dad didn't do anything wrong.
But even Wendell seems to have his doubts
he asks "Does it have something to do with the sound in the woods?"
The kid is brought into the
jail where Henry is held and proceeds to tell
him that he's not supposed to be there
in this timeline
If he doesn't get back to the woods in time he could be stuck
there forever and things will only get worse.
More people will die. But Henry isn't buying it.
He asks what would have happened to Ruth in the
kids timeline if she hadn't left. To which the kid says:
"Matthew would've shoot her" than recites the line
from Romans 6:23
a line that only Henry would know.
At the Deaver home Jackie puts Ruth to bed
which I thought was a bit weird bacause
I don't think that Jackie and Ruth have been into a scene together
unless Molly told her to take care of Ruth off screen
while she deals with Wendell.
The guards make Henry go to the kid cell
to make room for the Shawshank prisoners
that where in the bus that ran over warden Porter.
They recognize the kid calling him by
his nick name:
Nick Cage which Zaleski told us about in an earlier episode.
Ruth grabs the knight chess piece and holds it to her heart
The piece symbolizing her knight
Alan Pangborn, it is also the last
shot of Sissy Spacek we see this season
One of the prisoners stabs another one with a shank resulting in the wounded
prisoner to be let out.
He grabs one of the guard's gun, shoots
the rest and freeze the other prisoners.
All when Henry looks at the kid in other shaw
as if he's orchestrating the whole thing. The keys
convenient slide into the cell which the kid uses to take
Henry upstairs where all the other cops have been shoot
Henry finds Willie clinging to life
with his final words he says "Don't go out there"
as the kid points a gun on Henry saying "we have to go"
and if you believe the kid's story he told Molly
in episode 9 can you blame him he's been
trapped in this world for 27 years about to lose
his only way home wouldn't you do the same?
or perhaps he's needing Henry for more nefarious porpoises
Explosions and mayhem glitter the street of Castle Rock as the escape
prisoners roam free. Henry is taken to the forest where
the sound of the skisma gets louder and he
experiences more and more flashbacks.
Young Henry having run away from his father
almost falls over the edge of Castle Rock bluff
He carefully walks backwards
avoiding making new snow tracks to trick his father
to think he went over the edge and his plan
works. As Matthew looks over the presbi
Henry pushes his father over
fearing what he would do to his mother.
The helicopter provides a moment of distraction
which Henry uses to attack the kid. He wrestles his gun from his hand
gaining the apprehend and pointed at him.
Before we see that might be the most shocking
moment in the entire series
the kid transforms into an old disfigured man
that lets out a terrifying shrek
is thi the devil?
something else? or is it all in Henry's mind?
the answer? there is non.
and that's the point of the show
Starting back in episode one were giving
different perspectives of several key events and is up to us
the viewer
to piece everything together and make a judgment for
ourselves. Think of it like being in a court
in fact it's even a hint of that in episode 3
at the unjust convention of Molly with the kids
Warden Lacy, Henry Deaver, Alan Pangborn
are the prosecution claiming that the kid is the devil
Whereas the kid is the defense
In fact, a whole episode is devoted to
hearing his side of the story
We as the viewer are the jury
But as Henry says in his voice over a year later
truth isn't the same as justice, justice is a line that
sweaves and that's the same in real life.
People who are guilty get off and some were
innocent are sent to jail, it happens all the time.
Which leads us to the question of reasonable doubt.
At the very beginning of this episode we get an extended
scene of Henry talking to the jury
on the murder case of Lyann Chambers from episode 1
the jury blurred here is us
Henry is talking directly to us asking
"How much doubt are we comfortable with?" because for him
if someones life was on the line just like Lyann
the lady who gets the life penalty
He'd needs it etched in gold and sang by God himself.
in this place into why warden Lacy wouldn't kill the kid
and he even said it himself
deep down he has his doubts. what if the kid
wasn't evil and he was torturing this person by keeping him
cooped up in this cage for years
back in the way we have so much soad that when it's revealed
Henry's been keeping the kid in the water tank
the kid remarks
"After awhile you forget which side of bars you're on"
He's referring to the metaphor of prison
Henry and Lacy have had to live
not knowing the truth about the kid and the reasonable
doubt that he could not be evil
this is why he would struggle day and a day out
until he kills himself or passes on the beton
similar to what Lacy did. the kid even asks
"how much longer are we going to keep doing this?"
to which Henry response "i don't know"
Henry doesn't have a plan because he doesn't know
what to do and he doesn't know
what to believe. He's struggling in his own
prison of self doubt. So if you felt that the end
of this episode that you were cheated you have every right to be
there were countless loose sands and unanswered questions
not to mention the lack of the climax
but also understand that the ambiguous ending
was the whole point of the show. It was an allegory for justice
What would you do if the kid was on trial
and you had to make the decision to sentence him to death?
Would you? Is there enough reasonable doubt
Or would you struggle like Henry and Lacy did?
by having an unclear cut ending the show wonders would've likely given
us a better more obvious ending
at the expense of depriving us at a even more
discussion that of justice
Did i like the ending? Well first i hated it.
but i slowly started to warm up to it
knowing the grater amount of care
all the way from episode 1 and the story this writers wanted to tell
a story with greater teams
who make us question justice in our society today
but i wanna hear your thoughts in the comments below
and i may even do a full video just on the kid
expanding on my ideas here
but we still have a bit more story to get to
after seeing creepy monster kid we
flight in time an entire year. It looks like Henry has been found
innocent of Gordon and his wife's murder, Odin's
and any of the cops in the prisoner escape. Henry has stayed in Castle Rock
helping a man out with some property law
referring to Will
another character from "Needful Things"
he comes home to find the house with
Christmas decorations and that Wendell has come home for the holidays
this time he's actually happy to see him
and not rapped up into a video game
they play a game of chess were you'll notice all the Ruth's pieces are back
hinting that she's passed away. Molly took Henry's advice
and kept on driving
all the way down to Florida to live with her granmother
as Henry's voice
over explains that some people live Castle Rock
just to forget
hopefully Molly can find some happiness here
but it's not looking likely. Henry visits Ruth and Alan's grave
which is right next to the Deaver boy's
and we get to see that Henry has trapped the kid in the water tank
just like Lacy did. He brings him a Christmas present
a burger and fries
an odd to give someone you think is the devil
hinting again at Henry's doubts
this scene ends with the kid reminding Henry how things turned out
for warden Lacy. As we get to see this
creepy smile before fading to black
Is he good? Is he evil?
Is it something else? No one can explain that
Because it's up for you to decide
last but not least i hope you
stick around for the mid
credits role of Jackie finishing her book at the Mealow Tiger
talking with her local drug dealer, Dean
Jackie explains she's going out west for research
the name of the book overlook
is similar with the overlook hotel where "The Shining" took place
hinting that the next season will have a
large Shining conection
and would likely feature more of Jackie's character